wonder woman 1984 is a thrilling movie
and it's also jam-packed with subtle
details
from radical color schemes to feral
fashion to call backs to comic books and
ancient myth
here are some of the small details you
may have missed warning
if you still haven't seen wonder woman
1984 spoilers are on their way
rainbow's first pop-up in a themaskira
flashback in which young diana and her
older competitors are required to hit
targets releasing colored smoke to
signal how far they progressed
more rainbows pour in as we switch to
1984 and are dazzled by multi-colored
flashes from maxwell lord's television
ads
sharp by viewers will also notice that
the jogger threatened by reckless
drivers is wearing a rainbow top
the rainbows continue to appear
throughout the film's run time note that
max's son allister is wearing a rainbow
striped shirt when he's reunited with
his father toward the end of the film
perhaps most obviously there is the
fireworks display steve and diana fly
through which creates a kaleidoscope of
rainbows
even the dangerous dreamstone continues
the theme barbara notes it's made of
citrine
which can contain rainbow-like sparkles
you could just take this imagery as a
nod to the neon bright styles of the 80s
but it's likely there's a deeper meaning
intended
while wonder woman 1984's release date
was changed because of the cobit 19
pandemic the film was originally meant
to be released in june 2020
which would have seen it debut during
lgbtq pride month
director patty jenkins made a point of
not only revealing the release date on
twitter but of unveiling a rainbow
themed promotional poster along with it
wonder woman 1984 doesn't spend much
time going over the fates of diana's
friends and allies from a previous movie
but an early scene introducing diana's
apartment and the photos and other
memorabilia she keeps there makes it
clear she hasn't forgotten these people
in particular we see a photo of diana
with an elderly woman who can only be
out of candy
lucy davis plays the funny and fierce
edit candy in 2017's wonder woman
as steve trevor's secretary edda takes
an instant liking to diana and helps her
blend in with the people of 1918
london she may not be one of the more
action-oriented characters of the film
although i am not opposed to engaging in
a bit of fisticuffs
should the occasion arise edda was also
kind enough to educate the public about
the history of the amazons during the
lead-up to wonder woman's blu-ray
release
predicting the story could make a
tantalizing cereal
the picture reveals diana and etta
remained good friends for many years
after the war
etta's fate isn't specifically mentioned
in wonder woman 1984
though considering she would be roughly
in her 90s by the events of the film
there's a good chance she's passed on
one of the first victims of maxwell
lord's hunt for fortune is black gold
cooperative investor simon stagg
the first time we see max visit his
offices the place is practically empty
stagg is one of the only people there he
tells maxis discover the con man
is lying about his assets and warns him
he's going to report him to the
authorities
it may seem regrettable that max's
dreamstone powers stop stag from putting
lord behind bars
but if this simon stag is anything like
the one from the source material
odds are he deserves everything max does
to him and more
in the comics simon stag is the ceo of
stack enterprises
it's the offices of this company that
max visits just before getting stag
arrested in the film
stag is most often associated with the
strange transformation-centric hero rex
mason
aka metamorpho rex is in love with
simon's daughter sapphire and simon's
attempt to arrange rex's death is what
transforms rex into the heroic
metamorpho while simon stag isn't
exactly an a-list dc villain
wonder woman 1984 isn't actually his
first screen adaptation
stag is shown up in several dc-based
animated television series
including justice league and young
justice you may also recall him playing
a critical role in the 2015 video game
batman arkham knight
his only other live-action appearance
comes courtesy of william sadler in the
first season of the cw's the flash
the first time we see the inside of
diana's apartment it's clear the
connections she made during world war 1
remain important to her
we see a number of photos of friends and
soldiers on display as well as keepsakes
and pictures of her fall in love steve
trevor
one of her more prominent photographs
actually implies that diana either spent
a good deal of money paying tribute to
trevor
or visited his childhood home after
arriving in the states
the photograph accompanying steve's
watch shows diana alone
standing under a sign that reads trevor
ranch we don't get a story to accompany
the photo but it seems likely that
either the ranch diana visits belongs to
steve's family
or that she established it herself at
some point after world war 1 to honor
him
either way a photo of this ranch is a
remarkably clever tribute if you think
about it
unlike some of her other photos there's
nothing in the picture revealing diana
was alive during the events of world war
one
thus potentially revealing diana is far
more than an average anthropologist
though curious visitors might wonder why
she has a picture of herself taken at a
ranch without any horses in frame
they won't look at it and assume she's
an immortal amazon princess
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed the ruthless cheetah is one
of wonder woman's oldest adversaries
and kristen wiig's betrayal does her
major justice for most of the film
barbara minerva keeps her human looks
though she changes from the mousy
scientists we meet in the beginning of
the movie into an intimidating
powerhouse
it isn't until her final clash with
diana that we see her in full feline
glory complete with fur and claws
there are plenty of visual cues
throughout the film that set us up for
her metamorphosis
when barbara meets diana one of the
first things she notices are the hero's
leopard print heels
this is fitting since it's diana who
barbara wants to be when she makes her
fateful dreamstone wish
moreover the first embarrassing outfit
steve trevor tries on for diana includes
a leopard print top
and maxwell lord's lavish office
includes fur accessories
alongside all this feline passion
there's also a taxidermied wildcat often
seen behind barbara when she's at the
smithsonian
cat imagery isn't the only visual cue
used to illuminate barbara's story
when she begins to discover her newfound
super strength and goes to a gym to
gauge exactly how strong
she is she's dressed in a blue outfit
it's probably not a mistake that this is
the same color representing young diana
during the themisquirin games
plenty of dc comics fans will likely
recognize the name of the dreamstone as
soon as they hear it
in the comics this stone is most closely
associated with the villain doctor
destiny and the godlike dream of neil
gaiman's seminal sandman comics
but considering both its physical
appearance and its abilities wonder
woman 1984's dreamstone takes
inspiration from both its comic book
namesake and another dc comics artifact
many comics fans have identified the
mysterious object as the chaos crystal
or one of its powerful shards
this crystal first appears in 2013's
batman superman number three
like the film's dreamstone the chaos
crystal has wish-granting abilities
it's also said that the chaos crystal
comes from the sphere of the gods a
reality where many of the dc
universe's deities exist indeed when
diana first examines the dreamstone in
the film she's shocked to discover
writing in the language of the gods
notably the dreamstone of the source
material grants the ability to reshape
reality and pull
images from dreams but does not actually
require a specific wish
so while the artifact in question is
called the dreamstone in the film its
abilities are arguably closer to that of
the chaos crystal
though we have to admit dreamstone does
sound cooler
all you need is to want it on the
surface maxwell lord is significantly
different from the lord of the comics
his origin story powers and the
abilities he eventually gains from the
dreamstone aren't at all similar to
those of his comic book counterpart
but the makers of wonder woman 1984 pay
visual tribute
to the source material in a very
specific way comic fans will notice
when max goes to the oval office
granting the u.s president's wish turns
out to be more of a physical strain for
lord than any of the wish granting we've
seen him pull off previously
before max can finish creating all the
new missile sites for the president and
everything that goes along with it we
see a single stream of blood trickle
from max's nostril to his lips
this isn't a particularly unique visual
nor is it surprising considering the
epic scope of what max is creating but
in this case it's a clear tribute to his
comic book roots
when max is introduced in 1987's justice
league number one he doesn't have any
superhuman abilities
but after the events of the 1988 dc
comics lion wide event invasion and its
accompanying miniseries the detonation
of the so-called gene bomb gives max the
ability to mentally control other
people's actions
using this power always gives max a
nosebleed just like the one he gets in
the white house
when we first meet maxwell lord he's
introduced as the famous ceo of the
black gold cooperative
sharp-eyed viewers will notice that his
company's logo is a warning for what the
villain has in store for the world
it bears two columns of half circles
like rings snapped in half
facing away from each other what if
anything does that signify
for the answer we need only look back at
the beginning of the film which opens
with the themisquirin olympics
in the comics diana must triumph in a
similar competition for the right to
leap themschira and accompany steve
trevor to man's world
in the real world what image is most
closely associated with the olympics
the multicolored olympic rings of course
which are connected to represent the
nations of the world united in peaceful
competition
if an image of linked rings is meant to
symbolize the united world then what
does the logo for max's company
represent
its severed rings warn us of what max's
dreamstone creates by the end of wonder
woman 1984
a disconnected and divided world
erupting in chaos and violence
in mid-december 2020 gal gadot revealed
she wouldn't be the only member of her
family appearing in wonder woman 1984.
the actress disclosed that both her
husband and her daughters would make
cameos in the sequel
not long after director patty jenkins
said her son would also appear in the
flick
we can't point you toward every one of
these cameos jenkins said her son
appears in the film three different
times but we know of at least one
appearance
it's perhaps the briefest attack on
diana prince in the film
after max renounces his wish and his
plans are thwarted diana is accidentally
pelted with a snowball as a young boy
and girl play nearby
they apologize as she walks away though
obviously diana feels more amused than
anything else
the boy is patti jenkin's son asa and
his snowball rival is gadot's older
daughter alma
funnily enough gedut was pregnant with
her youngest daughter maya while filming
2017's wonder woman
they cut a big triangle and painted
green
and i came to work me and maya we came
to work
together so in a way maya had already
made a cameo though obviously without
any wardrobe or dialogue
wonder woman 1984 wouldn't really be a
superhero movie if there weren't a post
or mid-credit scene would it
paddy jenkins makes good on this with a
fun scene revealing the fate of hysteria
the ancient amazon hero who originally
wore the golden winged armor and held
off boards of men so her sisters could
be free
in the scene a dark-haired woman in blue
effortlessly stops a falling wooden post
with a single hand
saving a young girl when the girl's
mother stops the mystery woman to thank
her we learn that not only is she the
legendary hero hysteria but that she's
played by none other than linda
carter if you're too young to recognize
carter or just not up in your superhero
media the actress is best known for
playing wonder woman in the beloved 1975
television series
including her as something of a
predecessor to gal gadot's diana and the
eu is a wonderfully fitting stroke of
brilliance
what's your name wonder woman
this isn't the only time carter's been
called back to the superhero world
either
the actress played the principal in 2005
sky high made a one-off appearance on
smallville
and landed the recurring role of
president olivia marsden on the cw
supergirl
who is forced to resign from office when
it's discovered she's from outer space
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one